when you work with uh because you've you  work with a guy like muster who again a  modern day Legend yeah one of the best  producers of Our Generation you've  worked with the a what's the creative  difference between those two guys in the  studio  the uh individuals  uh yay has the way he does it must has  the way he does [ __ ] it's completely  different but  I mean you can hear it I just mean like  in terms of like the process because I  always hear yay is like more sporadic  like sometimes he just might set up a  [ __ ] microphone in the corner over  there and like but most of them may do  the same thing so it's just different  styles you know we came up different  ways and  have different techniques of doing this  [ __ ] but at the end of the day we all  make bangers so but way different  ways of doing this there's just a  different route to getting to the Banger  with each person right